[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a short korean horror drama
film called human form
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
in the opening scene we are introduced
to a five-year-old korean girl named
chang yin-hyung she is on the floor of
her bedroom drawing in her sketchbook in
hyung loves to draw pictures of girls
with colorful eyes and exaggerated
facial features her creations are often
artistic and advanced for a child it is
one of her many talents admired by her
teachers and family in hyung's mother
enters the room before asking her what
she is up to she has seen in young draw
beautiful pictures several times but the
girl never fails to surprise her mother
this particular drawing impresses her
more than usual to glorify it even more
she frames it and puts it on the wall of
her bedroom beside the picture are
several other drawings that yin hyung
has made in the past all of them are
unique but have a common theme in hyung
looks at the wall and smiles at her
accomplishment strangely enough we
notice that the mother doesn't show us
her face throughout the scene after that
the scene cuts to several years later in
hyung has grown up into a teenage girl
who is obsessed with her looks one
morning she is waiting outside the
school for her best friend while waiting
she looks at herself in a mirror
nitpicking the imperfections of her face
throughout her childhood she used to do
the same to her drawings but as she grew
up inhyung started treating her face
like a canvas the transition is not
particularly a good thing for her since
she is too harsh on herself as she
silently complains about her face her
friend rushes to her and apologizes for
being late they hold hands and make
their way to the cosmetic doctor
inhyeng's obsession with having a
perfect face has grown exponentially
over the years now that she is old
enough to get plastic surgery she wants
to change her entire face to look like
the models on billboards the friends
patiently wait for their appointment in
the lounging area they are nervous since
the day is one of the most important
days of their lives as they talk we find
out that inhyeng hasn't told her parents
about the appointment she hopes they
won't object because plastic surgery has
become something quite common in the
modern world her friend however is
seemingly nervous about the plan
suddenly she asks to see in hyung's
sketchbook it is then revealed that she
never stopped making bizarre sketches of
women like she used to but since they
are very personal to her she refuses to
show the sketchbook to her friend the
girl doesn't care about her privacy and
repeatedly insists whenin hyung still
doesn't agree she takes her bag and
forcefully gets the sketchbook out
fortunately for in hyung before her
friend can get a look at the pages a
nurse calls her name she takes a deep
breath before walking in to see the
doctor she also brings the sketchbook
with her as reference pictures she
excitedly shows them to the doctor
waiting for her reaction however her
heart shatters into pieces when the
doctor laughs at her drawings the woman
can almost not believe that inhyeong
wants to look as horrendous as these
pictures inhyeong still hopes that
surgery would be possible but is
informed that her wish is too
unrealistic since her face is structured
entirely differently from the sketches
it is impossible for them to reframe it
in the way she wants she is bluntly
asked to give up on her dreams but in
young doesn't want to return home
empty-handed she starts arguing with the
doctor and tells her that the picture is
not so different from the doctor's face
herself the doctor doesn't fancy being
disrespected by a schoolgirl she puts in
hyung in her place stating that even if
they could do the surgery a girl like
her would never be able to afford it
hopefully the doctor has a treatment for
that burn their clinic is exclusive to
the rich and inhung is definitely not
one of them until now we have not seen
the doctor's face suddenly the camera
pans towards her to reveal her heavily
modified and scary looking features her
skin is like that of a porcelain doll
her chin is a naturally sharp and pointy
her eyes look animated and her nose is
unusually structured all this added with
the thin eyebrows make her look like a
haunted doll she has most definitely
gone under the knife several times to
get where she is it is almost surprising
that ian hyung has been talking to her
normally up until now but the biggest
surprise comes when she claims that she
wants to look like the doctor no matter
the cost of the procedures the doctor
gives in to her demands and tells her
the total cost the numbers make in hyung
turn around and return home without a
word she doesn't even talk to her friend
who is curious about how the appointment
went in the following scene in hyung is
at home she her mother and her sister
are chatting while enjoying dinner
together inhyeng is quiet because of the
incident of the day but the other two
talk about a man who was recently bitten
by a dog it turns out that the dog was
made to get plastic surgery to look
prettier the mother thinks it is strange
but inhyeng's elder sister argues animal
plastic surgery is a popular trend
inhyung takes this opportunity to tell
them that she also wants to go under the
knife then we get to see her mother and
sister's faces for the first time they
look identical to each other and to the
doctor who in young saw earlier it is
then revealed that the haunted doll look
is the new beauty standard every model
actor and internet personality has the
same face the trend has taken over the
world causing even the normal people to
look alike people go overboard with the
surgeries to look conventionally
attractive and uniqueness and facial
features is non-existent ignoring the
obvious difference between her and
inhum's face her sister asks her why she
wants plastic surgery they argue that
she is already beautiful but sound like
hypocrites to een hyung she glances at
them in disbelief asking them to look in
the mirror she wants to get her face
done before the yearbook picture no
matter what since her elder sister also
got plastic surgery in high school she
argues that it is only fair she gets it
as well but to her dismay the mother and
sister are against the idea they think
inhyeng is not ready for a life-altering
procedure and even if she is she needs
to pay for it herself several minutes
later the father joins them at the
dinner table his face confirms that the
trend is not limited to just women his
features are identical to his wife and
daughter except for the beard the family
continues eating in silence which the
father thinks is strange when he asks
them what is wrong inhyeong storms off
to her room leaving her plate of food
unfinished in the next scene we see in
hyung going to meet her friend she hopes
to freshen her mood but her heart drops
on getting a look at her friend's face
she has also gotten plastic surgery to
look like the rest of them the girl asks
in hyung if she likes the new look but
inhyeng is just too stunned to comment
she feels worse than she did earlier now
that she is the only odd one out in
hyung returns home without saying
anything to her friend on her way back
it starts to rain but she doesn't care
enough to wait for it to stop all in
hyung can think of is how ugly she looks
and how desperately she wants the
surgery suddenly her wish manifests
itself and she sees a notice on the wall
that catches her attention it advertises
free facial surgery from doctors who
wish to test their expertise on the
patients the person doing the surgery
would be a non-professional who might
mess up the face altogether but still
inhum is willing to take the risk
without wasting much time she signs up
for the free cosmetic surgery program
the very next morning she goes to the
doctor's office the man is a sketchy guy
who doesn't tell her much about the
procedure but since he has the same face
like everyone else in hyung believes he
will do a good job before the operation
starts in hyung is made to sign a
consent form that states if any mistake
is made during the surgery the
professionals will not be at fault since
in hyung already knows the risks in the
following scene she is on a hospital bed
ready for the operation in her dreams
she sees her post-surgery face wrapped
in bandages everything seems to have
gone smoothly her mother is behind her
taking the bandage off for the first
time to her delight her face looks
exactly how she wanted it to the mother
comes near and compares their faces but
she suddenly starts to panic at the same
time we hear the doctor asking in hyung
if she can hear him he also questions
her if she can open her eyes when he
gets no reply he nervously says that he
is messed up a clip of in hyung shows us
her face wrapped in bloodied bandages
the procedure has gone horribly wrong in
the last scene we see in hyung's family
at the dinner table enjoying a meal some
minutes later in hyung returns home and
joins them the family completely ignores
her presence at first after a few
minutes or so they abruptly stop eating
and turn to her in sync the movie ends
as they continue staring at her and we
never get to see the results of the
surgery
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching